Margot Robbie is known for taking on challenging
roles that portray fascinating characters,
so it should be no surprise that
she had a specific condition for
playing the most recognizable doll in the world.
It might be hard to imagine anybody besides Margot
Robbie as Barbie even though there were originally
other actors attached to the long-awaited "Barbie"
movie. Still, according to a new article in Time,
Robbie wouldn't have taken the movie
if she was the only one playing Barbie.
"Hi, Barbie!"
"Hi Barbie."
"Hi Barbie!"
As the piece explains, Robbie's Barbie
definitely is the traditional version
of the character people remember: long
blonde hair, long tan legs, pink outfits,
the works. But after Mattel introduced a much
wider variety of Barbies into its roster, it made
it possible for the movie to depict the world's
most famous doll in many new ways. In fact,
Robbie revealed that, without other Barbies, she
wouldn't have been interested in the role, saying,
"If [Mattel] hadn't made that change to have a
multiplicity of Barbies, I don't think I would
have wanted to attempt to make a Barbie film.
I don't think you should say, 'This is the one
version of what Barbie is, and that's what women
should aspire to be and look like and act like.'"
Issa Rae agreed with Robbie, saying that
the sheer diversity of the cast is what
helped sell her on the "Barbie" movie as
a whole. Speaking with Time, she said,
"My worry was that it was going to feel
too white feminist-y, but I think that
it's self-aware. Barbie Land is perfect, right?
It represents perfection. So if perfection is
just a bunch of white Barbies, I don't know
that anybody can get on board with that."
The COO and president of Mattel, Richard Dickson,
made the argument that for people who only have
one version of Barbie already in their head,
Robbie's portrayal as the proto-Barbie is
simply a gateway to the others, saying,
"Of course she looks like Barbie.
But they're all Barbie. It's the
perfect cast to express what Barbie
is today. And Margot is the bridge."
Hari Nef, who plays Doctor Barbie in the film,
came into the project with her lived experience
as a trans woman, and she also felt comfortable
with and excited by the project thanks to
writer-director Greta Gerwig. She said,
"I knew this was not going to shy away
from the parts of Barbie that are more
interesting but potentially a little bit more
fraught. The contemporary history of feminism
and body positivity—there are questions
of how Barbie can fit into all of that."
As for what the "Barbie" movie is about, a lot
of the plot details have been kept under wraps,
but fans of writer-director Greta Gerwig,
and her co-writer and real-life partner Noah
Baumbach, know that this movie probably has
plenty of exciting tricks up its bright
pink sleeve. What we do know is that,
when she starts thinking about death too much
and her arched feet go flat, Robbie's Barbie
and her Ken head to the real world to figure out
how to solve this admittedly bizarre problem.
"No comment. No seriously, no comment."
In the Time piece, the cast remained fairly
mum about specific plot details, but Mattel
executives had some comments that turned out to be
pretty interesting. Beyond admitting that they'd
always hoped Robbie would play Barbie, executive
producer of Mattel Films Robbie Brenner said that
"Barbie" is "not a feminist movie." Robbie
had an interesting response to that, saying,
"It's not that it is or it isn't. It's a
movie. It's a movie that's got so much in
it. [The point is that] we're in on the
joke. This isn't a Barbie puff piece."
With all the anticipation
building for the "Barbie" movie,
are the powers that be eying a sequel?
It probably won't shock you to learn
that the Mattel executives aren't against the
idea. Mattel CEO Ynon Kreiz specifically says
that there's a possibility of "more Barbie
movies," but Robbie, once again, demurred:
"It could go a million different directions
from this point. But I think you fall into a
bit of a trap if you try and set up a first
movie whilst also planning for sequels."